this young girl says hi dad from a van
that supports children from
russian-controlled territory they're
reuniting in Kiev a moment he's been
anticipating for months these children
are among dozens who've been reunited
with their parents
our mission the rescue mission as we
call it ended today we returned 17
children who were deported to the
Russian Federation
many Ukrainian parents in
russian-controlled areas say they felt
pressure to send their children to what
they thought were summer camps but
instead they say they were places to
teach Russian patriotism
school because they would call and text
my grandmother saying if she didn't send
her child to school they would send me
to an orphanage my grandmother sent me
to school we studied there for about two
months maybe less and then we were told
that we can go to a camp for two weeks
she was deceived and in turn we were
deceived as well without any signatures
I was asking my mother how could they
take the child away I didn't sign I
didn't sign anything how my mother told
me they entered the house these big guys
came in with assault rifles it's scary
especially when a small three-year-old
child is running around it's scary
Ukraine's government says more than 16
000 children have been deported to
Russia to be placed in institutions and
Foster homes
while Moscow insists it's saving
Ukrainian orphans or unaccompanied
minors from the horrors of War
last week the international criminal
court issued an arrest warrant for
Russian President Vladimir Putin for the
illegal deportation of Ukrainian
children
Russia denied the allegations and then
issued criminal charges of its own
against the ICC for ignoring Putin's
immunity as Head of State under
international law back in Kiev children
who have been reunited with their
parents have been promised support and
counseling while they recover from their
ordeal
Laura Khan Al Jazeera